il y à un mois françois legault a
annoncé la fermeture des entreprises des
secteurs jugés non essentiels
aujourd'hui des détaillants dénoncent
une concurrence déloyale de la part des
grandes surfaces qui sont toujours
ouvertes
normand décarie et pdg des enseignes
serre et sportium sur décarie bonsoir
soient vos magasins sont fermés depuis
quand depuis le jour où on a annoncé la
fermeture des magasins jugés non
essentiels
oui c'est exactement ça combien de
magasins combien d'employés
le tout près de 1800 employés et 19
sites différents et comment vous vous en
sortez dans les circonstances ben
écoutez cette triste situation on peut
résumer en disant que nos ventes en
ligne se sont améliorées on peut dire
qu'elles ont à peu près d'oublier par
contre ça représente encore quinzaine de
points de la business si vous me
permettez l'expression d'un racisme
alors c'est 15% des affaires 15 18%
donc il ya 80% du chiffre d'affaires qui
est disparu et ce depuis un mois ou à
peu près est-ce que vous passer à
travers ça est ce que vous avez demandé
de l'aide du gouvernement
écoutez on est à l'affût des collèges et
dans un contexte comme celui qu'on vient
seulement on est dans des invasions de
capital
inutile de vous dire que ces ex cima
difficile de gérer avec un chef de file
qui était réduit de 80% dans l'obstacle
imiza guigli il les obstacles que que sa
cause avec les fournisseurs avec nos
bailleurs et tout ça alors
pour l'instant on s'en sort mais on
n'est toujours pas de date de retour et
c'est ce qui est le plus inquiétant
on peut pas planifier on peut pas
prévoir la date de toujours il existe un
vrai et
voyez en ce moment des concurrents des
grandes surfaces qui ont des activités
essentielles mais qui vendent aussi des
produits non essentiels jugés non
essentiels disons le dans des secteurs
non essentiels qui vous font concurrence
ça sacré c'est c'est quoi une
frustration chez vous mais oui dans le
sens où on comprend très bien les
frileux et il semble que oui et on on
s'assure de les respecter et je crois
que c'est une mesure qui doit être
respecté par tout le monde sauf que dans
l'interprétation des brevets essentiels
des grandes surfaces américain espère
vendre des articles de plein air dire
être même des fonctions alors que moi il
vient l'autre détail m on n'est pas
autorisée à ouvrir nos portes
alors vous comprendrez que c'est dans
cette optique là c'est une concurrence
tout à fait déloyal et qui aura des
conséquences quand viendra le temps de
rouvrir vous pensé pour vous pour vos
activités
bien sûr parce que non seulement c'est
grand c'est lyon surface américaine lah
continue de prospérer et d'avoir un
chiffre d'affaires soutenu nous
entreprises québécoises 100 % québécoise
aussi lui sportivement trop je suis pris
avec ma situation
les inventaires invendus et au moment de
la réouverture on comprendrait que les
clients que vont ils s'approvisionner
chez les jeux les grandes surfaces
américaine sans second pôle urgences et
le besoin de venir chez moi et j'ai tous
les autres détaillants qui ont été
fermés ouais et l'a donc de ce fait un
mois que ça dure donc en quelque sorte
anguilles mais le mal est fait mais pour
la suite des choses
qu'est ce que vous souhaiteriez de la
part du gouvernement du québec là dessus
ben pour l'instant du moins à très court
terme on souhaiterait bien évidemment
quelle discrimination au niveau de la
vendée
lui c'est à dire que si les produits ne
peuvent pas être vendus par les
détaillants québécois spécialisé
on va le dire comme ça personne devrait
pouvoir les vendre dans un premier temps
et l'on parle pas des produits
essentiels de nourriture et de pharmacie
non jeu complet et dans un dans une
optique de réouverture progressive
je pense que pour respecter les règles
de dix ans de distanciation les grandes
surfaces seront tout à fait adapté à
recevoir des clients tout en respectant
les règles de santé publique est dictée
par le gouvernement mais on ne peut pas
commencer uniquement par les petites
surfaces je pense que c'est beaucoup
plus la nature des produits et les pages
qu'on peut voir offrir aux clients pour
pouvoir magazine et en toute sécurité
avez vous parlé de vos inquiétudes et
incertitudes au gouvernement au ministre
de l'économie pierre fête cubaine par
exemple eu au nord envoyer des missives
à son cabinet oui et on s'est servi des
gens qui nous ont un rôle des groupes
comme le conseil québécois du commerce
de détail qui nous représente très bien
et qui ont des antennes au cabinet du
ministre et au cabinet du premier
ministre
alors oui sa part de nos doléances
est ce que le fonds s'effectue vous
vient en aide le fonds ftq est déjà
impliqué dans votre entreprise et le pdg
nous disait le fonds sera présent pour
la relance économique
oui mais il faut pas faut pas confondre
un environnement financier ou de legs ou
de l'encadrement des nazis ou des
allègements synergie avec une perte de
vente et un exode des clients m'ont
donné est ce que le panier bleus qui a
été lancée et est fait pour vous écouter
il n'y a pas de doute que c'est une
initiative qui mérite d'être mentionné
aucun doute là-dessus et c'est louable
sauf que dans un contexte où les grandes
chaînes
les grands concurrents américains
demeurent ouverts c'est un peu paradoxal
vous me permettrez ça manque ça change
pas grand chose pour vous 3 autrement
dit merci
c'est une excellente initiative et ça
met en veille est ce ça met en relief
les industries québécoises et on peut
pas être contre ça on peut absolument
pas être contre le seul bien sûr des
grilles on va s'arrêter là tu merci
d'avoir été avec nous ce soir belge est
bien gentil merci beaucoup merci bien